About the whole safety in C++ and the future of C++ and do you think it has one? Should we just let it die? Should we just go, well, you know, C++ has had its time and now we should move on to something new? Or do you think we should pursue trying to turn C++ into a safe language? Conor, what's your feeling on the matter? Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 223 recorded on February 17th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we continue our chat with Tristan Brindle. In today's episode, we chat about the recent C++ London meetup and whether C++ is dying or already dead. Should we switch to C++ London because you guys were both there and you sent me a photo? Oh that's right. Yeah. Yeah. I had FOMO. I was I I mean I should have figured that there was
关于C++的整体安全性以及C++的未来，你认为它还有未来吗？我们应该让它消亡吗？我们是否应该说，好吧，你知道，C++的时代已经过去了，现在我们应该转向一些新的东西？还是你认为我们应该继续努力将C++变成一种安全的语言？Conor，你对此有什么看法？欢迎收听ADSB播客第223期，录制于2025年2月17日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Ben一起，我们继续与Tristan Brindle的对话。在今天的节目中，我们聊到了最近的伦敦C++聚会，以及C++是否正在消亡或已经死亡。我们应该转到伦敦C++聚会吗？因为你们俩都在那里，而且你们还给我发了照片？哦，没错。是的。是的。我有错失恐惧症（FOMO）。我是说，我本应该想到会有
gonna be a meetup and Ben would be there and then you guys would bump into each other. Well, I only looked it up. You know, I planned my trip to England for the end of January and like a few days before I was due to go, I'm like, Oh, maybe I should look up and see if there's a something happening in the London meetup. And as it happened, a huge thing was happening. And there was like everyone flew in for it. It was the biggest meetup like in the history of the event,
一场聚会，Ben也会在那里，然后你们会碰面。好吧，我只是查了一下。你知道，我计划在一月底去英国旅行，在我出发前几天，我想，哦，也许我应该查查看伦敦聚会是否有活动。结果正好有一场大型活动。每个人都飞过去参加了。这是该活动历史上规模最大的一次聚会，
because it was a very kind of special occasion, because it was Bloomberg had organized this panel of, was it six or seven experts on the C++ contracts proposal to sort of come in and do a Q&A all about contracts. And it is recorded. Link in the description for those that were not able to attend in purpose. To attend in purpose. To attend in person.
因为这是一个非常特殊的场合，彭博社（Bloomberg）组织了一个由六七位专家组成的专家组，讨论C++合约提案，并进行了一场关于合约的问答环节。该环节已被录制。对于那些无法亲自参加的人，描述中有链接。亲自参加。
You can go click a link. I think it's like an hour and 40 minutes or an hour and 50 minutes or something like that. And I did hear Ben's voice on the mic at some point asking a question. I do not recall the question, but I do remember hearing your voice. I asked the question about whether contract handlers, there's a way with contracts to install
你可以点击链接。我想大约是一个小时40分钟或一个小时50分钟左右。我在某个时候确实在麦克风里听到了Ben的声音在提问。我不记得问题是什么了，但我确实记得听到了你的声音。我问的问题是关于合约处理程序，是否有办法通过合约来安装
a user defined handler for contract violations. That's the way I was looking for. That is, I asked whether that was possible at compile time. It is not. It is link time only. So it's a runtime thing. Although everything else about contracts pretty much can work at constexpr time as well. That is the one part that unfortunately can't.
一个用户定义的合约违规处理程序。这就是我一直在寻找的方法。也就是说，我问这是否可以在编译时实现。答案是不行。它只能在链接时实现。所以这是一个运行时的事情。尽管关于合约的其他一切几乎都可以在constexpr时间工作。这是唯一一个不幸无法做到的部分。
And the implications of that are that you can't entirely do contract checking at compile time? You can do contract checking at compile time, but you can't have a user defined violation handler. I see. So I mean, I'm guessing that you were hoping that you could do some kind of custom injection of some, I don't know error message or Well, if you can if you could do that a compile time it would mean that you could
这意味着你不能完全在编译时进行合约检查？你可以在编译时进行合约检查，但不能拥有用户定义的违规处理程序。我明白了。所以我想你当时是希望能够进行某种自定义注入，比如，我不知道，错误信息，或者……好吧，如果你能在编译时做到这一点，那就意味着你可以
Effectively do user formatted compile time warnings Yeah, yeah You do some ASCII art in there or something if you really wanted to Yeah any any or something if you really wanted to. Well, if you wanted to, yeah. Yeah. So I mean, people can go watch the talk, but any behind the scenes chats or gossip that you guys can share with the listeners of before or after, or was it just, people showed up, people left?
有效地进行用户格式化的编译时警告。是的，是的。如果你真的想的话，你可以在里面做一些ASCII艺术之类的东西。是的，任何东西，如果你真的想的话。好吧，如果你想的话，是的。是的。所以，人们可以去观看这次演讲，但你们有什么幕后花絮或八卦可以分享给听众吗？是在开始之前还是结束之后？还是说只是大家来了又走了？
I think about gossip, I mean, I'm not sure if, I hadn't public that to any of my London friends that I was coming. I had signed up because, you know, signing up for meetups is a good thing to do because it influences, you know, the organizers know how many people are coming, what the kind of food and drink situation is, that kind of thing. So I had actually signed up, but I was signed up number 120, whatever, I don't know. I was down in the weeds. It wasn't like I signed up first so everyone could see that I was coming. So I just rock up and I see Gashper and Gashper's jaw drops onto the floor and he's all excited and waves at me
关于八卦，我是说，我不确定，我没有向任何伦敦的朋友公开我要去的消息。我报名了，因为你知道，报名参加聚会是一件好事，因为它会影响……组织者知道有多少人会来，食物和饮料的情况如何，诸如此类的事情。所以我确实报名了，但我报名的编号是120号，不管怎样，我不知道。我只是在人群中。并不是说我第一个报名，所以每个人都能看到我要去。所以我只是走过去，看到Gashper，Gashper的下巴都惊掉了，他非常兴奋，向我挥手，
and then Tristan shows up and it's a good time. Gashper's like Tristan, Tristan, have you met Ben D? And the very first thing I said was, what the hell are you doing here? Which now I think about it, I probably could have been a bit friendlier, Ben, so sorry about that. But what I meant was,
然后Tristan也出现了，那是一段美好的时光。Gashper说：“Tristan，Tristan，你见过Ben D吗？”我说的第一句话是：“你到底在这里干什么？”现在回想起来，我可能应该更友好一点，Ben，所以对此感到抱歉。但我的意思是，
it was a bit of a surprise to see you. No, you know, that's how British people treat each other. That is totally friendly. Yeah. Yes, yes. Man of the moment, Gashper, who is gonna be,
看到你有点惊讶。不，你知道，这就是英国人对待彼此的方式。这完全是友好的。是的，是的。当下的风云人物Gashper，他将要，
seem to be one of the most important people in C++, I think, has been appointed editor of the Safety White Paper. I don't know if you've seen that. Ah, right. I have not seen that. Along with Herb, they're going to... Between the two of them, I believe.
似乎是C++中最重要的人之一，我想，他被任命为安全白皮书的编辑。我不知道你是否看到了。啊，对了。我没看到。和Herb一起，他们将……我相信他们两人之间。
Interesting. So that's going to be... Actually, let's go on a tangent. I'm going to be the host for a moment. I'm going to ask you two questions. Or a question about the whole Safety in C++ and the future of C++ and do you think it has one? Should we just let it die? Should we just go, well, you know, C++ has had its time and now we should move on to something new? Or do you think we should pursue trying
有趣。所以那将是……实际上，让我们离题一下。我要当一会儿主持人。我要问你们两个问题。或者关于C++整体安全性和C++未来的问题，你认为它还有未来吗？我们应该让它消亡吗？我们是否应该说，好吧，你知道，C++的时代已经过去了，现在我们应该转向一些新的东西？还是你认为我们应该继续努力
to turn C++ into a safe language? What do you all, Connor, what's your feeling? I want Ben to go first. I mean, this is, this sounds like it's a revisiting of episode 150 when we, Bryce and I sub-podded that other podcast and they were all like, it's dead, blah, blah, blah. I think the podcast episode was, is C++ dying? So I don't know if we're going to call this one,
将C++变成一种安全的语言？你们大家怎么看，Connor，你的感觉是什么？我想让Ben先说。我的意思是，这听起来像是重温第150期节目，当时Bryce和我代班了另一个播客，他们都在说，它死了，等等等等。我想那期播客的主题是，C++正在消亡吗？所以我不知道我们是否要称这一期为，
is C++ dying 2.0 or addition, addition two? I'll let Ben go first. Well, I have opinions. I have observations. Obviously, C++ isn't dying for the same reason that COBOL isn't dead. It's past the threshold of immortality. That's a trivial thing to say. But with safety in particular, it seems like no one's realized the impact of the current geopolitical climate on the safety conversation. Who is now going to fund work on safety? Nobody has an incentive to do so. The US government is deregulating everything. You know, there is simply going to be no pressure from the US government anymore for the next at least four years, probably longer, to do anything with safety. That's the sad fact. So you know, even if C++ gets safety in some form, there is no incentive for any tech company to work on it.
C++正在消亡2.0或第二版？我会让Ben先说。好吧，我有我的观点。我有我的观察。显然，C++并没有消亡，原因和COBOL没有死一样。它已经跨过了不朽的门槛。这是一个陈词滥调。但特别是关于安全性，似乎没有人意识到当前地缘政治气候对安全对话的影响。现在谁还会资助安全方面的工作？没有人有动力这样做。美国政府正在放松一切管制。你知道，在未来至少四年，甚至可能更长时间内，美国政府根本不会有任何压力去做任何关于安全的事情。这是一个可悲的事实。所以你知道，即使C++以某种形式获得了安全性，也没有任何科技公司有动力去研究它。
The implementation of said safety will not occur to a first approximation. You know, we're seeing already tech companies just changing things in response to the current administration. Now, you know, this doesn't take into account Europe, the European Union, which is a force for good maybe in this. We'll have to wait and see but I certainly think that the current climate has not only taken the wind out of safety but even reversed it, very sadly. We don't have to be happy about that, of course. So that's just an observation that I have. It's very similar to what happened. You know, a lot of people, again, we can sort of learn from history. If you are old enough to be working professionally around 2000, you may remember which some of our listeners no doubt were.
上述安全性的实现将不会发生，至少在第一近似值上是这样。你知道，我们已经看到科技公司为了应对现任政府而改变了一些事情。现在，你知道，这没有考虑到欧洲，欧盟，这在其中可能是一股向善的力量。我们拭目以待，但我当然认为，当前的气候不仅让安全工作失去了动力，甚至非常可悲地将其逆转了。当然，我们不必为此感到高兴。这只是我的一个观察。这和发生过的事情非常相似。你知道，很多人，同样，我们可以从历史中学习。如果你年纪够大，在2000年左右从事专业工作，你可能还记得，毫无疑问我们的一些听众记得。
I have friends who were working at Microsoft then. Microsoft was being investigated for antitrust by the Department of Justice. Microsoft was in potentially quite a lot of trouble. They were talking about splitting up the company, all those kinds of things. When the Bush administration came in, it pretty much went away overnight
我有朋友当时在微软工作。微软当时正因反垄断受到司法部的调查。微软可能陷入了相当大的麻烦。他们当时在讨论拆分公司，诸如此类的事情。当布什政府上台时，它几乎在一夜之间就消失了，
from what I heard from people who worked at Microsoft at the time. And the same thing is happening here. Safety has gone away overnight, or at least the incentives to become safe in the US have disappeared overnight. A very good observation. But a part of my, there's a voice in the back of my head that says even though that's the case it's probably not going to Halt the committee's desire to make progress in that space because regardless of the current administration in the US
这是我从当时在微软工作的人那里听到的。同样的事情也发生在这里。安全性在一夜之间消失了，或者至少在美国变得安全的动力在一夜之间消失了。一个非常好的观察。但我脑海深处有一个声音说，即使情况如此，这可能也不会阻止委员会在该领域取得进展的愿望，因为无论美国现任政府如何，
long term it definitely seems like that is the the Long-term it definitely seems like that is the the the trend So even if we do take a four year break or an eight year break from the incentivization to do that My guess is that in two decades from now? It's gonna it's you know gonna the incentivization will Rematerialize at some points and well, I certainly hope so and don't get me wrong. There is still a moral imperative here Yeah, there is still a moral imperative here. There is just no structural financial imperative within society at the moment. Yeah. I guess in terms of like the my take on like dying or dead, like, you know, I agree with Ben in that
从长远来看，这绝对看起来是……从长远来看，这绝对看起来是……趋势。所以即使我们确实在激励机制上休息了四年或八年，我的猜测是，从现在起二十年后，它会……你知道，激励机制会在某个时候重新出现，好吧，我当然希望如此，别误会我的意思。这里仍然存在道德上的必要性。是的，这里仍然存在道德上的必要性。只是目前社会内部没有结构性的财务必要性。是的。我想关于“消亡”或“死亡”的看法，就像，你知道，我同意Ben的观点，
there's no such thing like C++ is dead. Whenever you hear people say that, I think they're playing fast and loose with that word. The question is, is it now on like a downtrend? Like has it peaked? And like over the next 50 years, pending that the AI singularity doesn't wipe out the planet or some other catastrophe, What's going to happen?
没有所谓的“C++已死”。每当你听到人们这么说时，我认为他们是在随意使用这个词。问题是，它现在是否处于下行趋势？比如它是否已经达到顶峰？在接下来的50年里，假设AI奇点没有消灭地球或其他灾难，会发生什么？
And from my point of view, there seems to be so much wind behind safe languages, primarily Rust at the moment. Like, I listen to a ton of other programming language podcasts, and I'm not really a part of those communities per se, maybe Python a little bit, but there's so much tooling and like transferring of tech written in a certain language to being written in Rust. And you never hear it happening to being written in C++. All these new JavaScript like runtimes,
从我的角度来看，安全语言似乎有很大的推动力，目前主要是Rust。比如，我听了很多其他编程语言的播客，我本身并不是那些社区的一员，也许Python稍微多一点，但有太多的工具，以及将用某种语言编写的技术转移到用Rust编写。你从来没听说过它被转移到用C++编写。所有这些新的JavaScript运行时，
like Dino, et cetera, Bun, all being written in Rust. All this Python tooling, you know, rough UV being written in Rust. Like all Python tooling, you know, rough UV being written in Rust. Like all of this like tech transfer that's happening to get these 100X speed ups from being implemented in Python or JavaScript or some other language and then re-implemented in a systems language, it always happens in Rust.
比如Deno等等，Bun，都是用Rust编写的。所有这些Python工具，你知道，Ruff、UV都是用Rust编写的。比如所有这些正在发生的技术转移，为了从Python或JavaScript或其他语言实现中获得100倍的速度提升，然后用系统语言重新实现，它总是发生在Rust中。
And I get the sense that like new projects in this kind of vein always happen in Rust. That doesn't mean that like C++ is going anywhere. I think Jason Turner, he had a C++ weekly video where he highlighted all of the massive software programs, Word, LibreOffice. He goes through just a ton. And they're all written in C++. And if you think about currently, there's this joke that like oh you should
我感觉到，这种类型的新项目总是发生在Rust中。这并不意味着C++会消失。我认为Jason Turner，他有一个C++ Weekly视频，他强调了所有的大型软件程序，Word，LibreOffice。他列举了非常多。它们都是用C++编写的。如果你想想目前，有一个笑话是，哦，你应该
You know when we're in the age where you should never need to manually manage memory, which is ridiculous I don't know if it's an XKCD or it's some like quote or whatever, but it says that like every single GC languages GC is implemented in C++ So it's like the ability to not use manual memory is due to manually managed memory and So I don't think C++ is gonna like it's according to rankings, you know rank number five or six depending on The language ranking. I don't think it's number two the new T-o-b-t-o-b. That's the worst index of all
你知道，在我们这个时代，你永远不需要手动管理内存，这很荒谬。我不知道这是XKCD还是什么名言，但它说，每一个GC语言的GC都是用C++实现的。所以就像，不使用手动内存的能力归功于手动管理的内存，所以我不认为C++会……根据排名，你知道，排名第五或第六，取决于语言排名。我不认为它是第二，新的TIOBE。那是所有指数中最糟糕的。
It's apparently this is like people have just been Are you kidding me? worse index of all. Apparently this is like people have just been Are you kidding me? I'm pulling it up right now. TIOB stands for the importance of being earnest. The irony not lost there. Look at that, folks. Python number one, C++
显然，这是人们只是……你在开玩笑吗？最糟糕的指数。显然，这是人们只是……你在开玩笑吗？我正在查它。TIOBE代表“The Importance of Being Earnest”（认真的重要性）。讽刺意味不言而喻。看看那个，伙计们。Python第一，C++
number two. But let me, let me, you know. Highest position since 1995, I read somewhere. Fortran is number 11. Delphi slash Object Pascal number nine visual basic number 10 typescript doesn't even make the top 20 I think it's ranked like let's find it folks 38th and on every other single measuring site or ranking site it's a top 10 language and I think we we've got Prolog is making a comeback. One of the fastest growing languages at number 20. And and so just like I have, I don't know what is up with this site,
第二。但让我，让我，你知道。我读到过，这是自1995年以来的最高排名。Fortran是第11位。Delphi/Object Pascal第9位，Visual Basic第10位，TypeScript甚至没有进入前20名，我想它排名大约是……让我们找找，伙计们，第38位。而在其他每一个衡量网站或排名网站上，它都是前10名的语言，而且我认为我们……Prolog正在卷土重来。增长最快的语言之一，排名第20。所以就像我一样，我不知道这个网站是怎么回事，
but I actually it's still included. The link is still included on my PL rank dot com site. But I have disabled the ability to include it in the average because I just have checks checkboxes to, you know, calculate the the average because I just have check boxes to calculate the weighted average. I've excluded it. You're no longer able to include it because I think it's such a bad site.
但我实际上它仍然被包括在内。这个链接仍然包含在我的PLrank.com网站上。但我已经禁用了将其包含在平均值中的功能，因为我只是有复选框来，你知道，计算……因为我只是有复选框来计算加权平均值。我已经排除了它。你不再能够包含它，因为我认为它是一个非常糟糕的网站。
And so whenever I hear podcasts linking to this, and don't get me wrong, I used to look at this site all the time because I see rankings, I see logos, I go, ooh, very nice. But then when I started noticing the changes from month to month when this gets updated I was like what the heck is going on here?
所以每当我听到播客链接到这个网站时，别误会，我过去经常看这个网站，因为我看到排名，我看到标志，我说，哦，非常好。但后来当我开始注意到每个月更新时的变化时，我就想，这到底是怎么回事？
Like the fact that TypeScript is 38th and that prologue and Fortran I'm not saying the Fortran isn't potentially a top 20 based on some metrics, but I mean It's probably not higher than TypeScript is all I'm saying. So but I guess Asterisk it is number two according to TIOBE. But yeah, I don't think it's going and it's not going to drop out of the top 20 in the next 30 years. I don't think it's going to be still one of the most popular languages and I still think there's going to be if you look at the number of jobs open per language, it still ranks one of the highest and I don't think that's going anywhere. The question
比如TypeScript排名第38位，而Prolog和Fortran……我不是说Fortran根据某些指标可能不是前20名，但我的意思是，它可能不会比TypeScript高，这就是我想说的。所以，但我想加个星号，根据TIOBE，它是第二名。但是的，我不认为它会消失，而且在未来30年内它不会跌出前20名。我不认为它会不再是最流行的语言之一，而且我仍然认为，如果你看看每个语言的职位空缺数量，它仍然排名最高，我不认为它会消失。问题
is is like the momentum, you know, like and I think we're gonna whether it's Rust or some other language. Yeah, I definitely think the momentum is going to be switching to and honestly, I'm not even sure it's safety to be honest. I think the tooling is my number one recommendation to the C++ community. If you can replicate the Rust up experience for C++ so that I don't need to go manually configure clang format, clang tidy, include what you use, cpp check, all this stuff. Rust up just does it for you. Not only does it do it for you, it initializes a git repo with your git setup and you can just immediately go git diff. It's amazing. I think 50% if not more of the reason Rust is doing so well is because of its tooling experience.
是，就像动力，你知道，我认为我们将……无论是Rust还是其他语言。是的，我绝对认为动力将会转移，老实说，我甚至不确定是不是安全性。我认为工具是我给C++社区的第一建议。如果你能为C++复制Rust-up的体验，这样我就不需要手动配置clang-format、clang-tidy、include-what-you-use、cppcheck，所有这些东西。Rust-up只是为你做了。它不仅为你做了，它还用你的git设置初始化了一个git仓库，你可以立即进行git diff。这太棒了。我认为Rust之所以表现这么好，50%甚至更多是因为它的工具体验。
It's not because it's a more pleasant language or whatever. Like safety is great, but I honestly, you know, for research work, I don't care about safety. I care about being able to prototype quickly, right? Not having to say stuff. We have to recognise also that we are talking about the sort of the pyramid here in terms of the privilege of being able to write in a desktop environment or in a server environment or in an environment that can support these kinds of things. One of these days, in one of my talks, I'll put a pie chart, which will be like number of processors in the world, and it'll be like desktop and server processors versus embedded processors. And the pie chart is just going to be one color.
并不是因为它是一种更令人愉快的语言或其他什么。比如安全性很好，但我老实说，你知道，对于研究工作，我不关心安全性。我关心的是能够快速原型设计，对吧？不必说那些东西。我们还必须认识到，我们在这里谈论的是金字塔，关于能够在桌面环境、服务器环境或能够支持这些东西的环境中编写代码的特权。有一天，在我的演讲中，我会放一个饼图，它将是世界上处理器的数量，它将是桌面和服务器处理器与嵌入式处理器。饼图将只有一种颜色。
It's going to be embedded processors because there won't be enough resolution to display the number of server and embedded processors in the world. Have you tried counting the embedded processors just in your room that you're in right now or in your house? Well let me tell you that every every desktop or server processor contains within it dozens of embedded processes. So that alone is going to mean that you know and programming embedded is still often done in C not even in C++.
它将是嵌入式处理器，因为没有足够的分辨率来显示世界上服务器和嵌入式处理器的数量。你试过数一下你现在所在的房间或房子里的嵌入式处理器吗？好吧，让我告诉你，每一个桌面或服务器处理器内部都包含数十个嵌入式处理器。所以仅此一点就意味着，你知道，而且嵌入式编程通常仍然是用C完成的，甚至不是用C++。
I do it in C++ and it certainly is possible in C++, but many, many people are still working in C and we still have to work in assembler sometimes. The idea of programming embedded in even Rust, let alone JavaScript, TypeScript, maybe another language, a safer language. We are a long way from that at the moment. Rust, Rust had, the reason I don't think Rust is taking over there anytime soon is, I mean, there are initiatives to do Rust on Embedded,
我用C++做，它在C++中当然是可能的，但许多许多人仍然在使用C工作，我们有时仍然必须使用汇编语言。在嵌入式中进行编程，即使是Rust，更不用说JavaScript、TypeScript，也许是另一种语言，一种更安全的语言。我们目前离那还很远。Rust，Rust有……我不认为Rust很快会接管那里，我的意思是，有一些在嵌入式上使用Rust的倡议，
I'm aware, and there are, you know, and Embedded is getting more capable, right? Embedded doesn't always mean bare metal. It might mean some embedded Linux distro, right? And in that case, maybe Rust is viable. But at the moment, C++ and LLVM are the only things that have a defined memory model. Every language that uses LLVM inherits the C++ memory model because it's what LLVM provides.
我知道，而且有，你知道，嵌入式变得越来越强大，对吧？嵌入式并不总是意味着裸机。它可能意味着一些嵌入式Linux发行版，对吧？在这种情况下，也许Rust是可行的。但目前，C++和LLVM是唯一具有定义内存模型的。每一种使用LLVM的语言都继承了C++内存模型，因为这是LLVM提供的。
And when you're doing work with interrupts, when you're doing that kind of work, you need to be able to reason about the memory model. That's one thing. At a higher level, when you're programming libraries, C++'s killer feature is variadic templates. Absolutely no doubt in my mind. I cannot understand why Rust is not scrambling to get variadic generics.
当你处理中断时，当你做那种工作时，你需要能够推理内存模型。这是一回事。在更高层面上，当你编写库时，C++的杀手级功能是可变参数模板。我心中绝对毫无疑问。我无法理解为什么Rust不争先恐后地获得可变参数泛型。
Apparently they've looked at it, they've decided it's not high priority. It is the single biggest feature for writing libraries. It is the most powerful feature. I contend. I mean, I know multiple people that have said that's the reason they prefer C++ to Rust is that they aren't leaving a language for another language that doesn't have variadic generics. And like I think even on Oxide and Friends, which was the podcast that we subpotted where they had a couple of people saying C++ is dead, they had one of their employees at Oxide like speak up and say that like, well, from a library implementer like point of view,
显然他们研究过它，他们决定这不是高优先级。它是编写库的单一最大功能。它是最强大的功能。我坚持认为。我的意思是，我认识多个人说过，这就是他们更喜欢C++而不是Rust的原因，因为他们不会为了另一种没有可变参数泛型的语言而离开一种语言。而且我认为即使在Oxide and Friends上，也就是我们代班的那个播客，他们有几个人说C++已死，他们有Oxide的一名员工站出来说，从库实现者的角度来看，
it is actually quite painful trying to do some of the stuff that's possible in C++. And I think he might have even like the tuple implementation example of doing this kind of stuff. Sure, we have macros and you can superficially get the same kind of thing, but that's not idiomatic Rust. You don't want to be in trait land and iterator land and then want to do something that's variadic and then have to reach for an iZip macro. It's just it's awkward. A lot of people don't even know it's there. And that's the solution
尝试做一些C++中可能的事情实际上是非常痛苦的。而且我认为他甚至可能像元组实现示例那样做这种事情。当然，我们有宏，你可以表面上得到同样的东西，但那不是地道的Rust。你不想在trait领域和迭代器领域，然后想做一些可变参数的事情，然后不得不去使用iZip宏。这很尴尬。很多人甚至不知道它的存在。这就是解决方案，
right now. I've asked a few Rust programmers, if you want to zip over a couple different sequences and then unpack it, how do you do that? And they're like, oh, well, you have destructuring in the parameter list. So I can just destructure a tuple where the second element is a tuple. And so your destructure is just like paren, a comma, paren, b comma c, end paren, end paren. It's not super elegant, but it does work. And the more you try and scale that, the worse it gets. But that was the answer I got.
现在。我问过几个Rust程序员，如果你想压缩几个不同的序列然后解包，你怎么做？他们说，哦，好吧，你在参数列表中有解构。所以我可以解构一个元组，其中第二个元素是一个元组。所以你的解构就像括号，a，逗号，括号，b，逗号，c，右括号，右括号。它不是超级优雅，但它确实有效。而且你尝试扩展它的次数越多，它就越糟糕。但这就是我得到的答案。
And the individual said, honestly, I acknowledge that C++'s solution is superior here. But that is something I'm willing. I'm not an implementer. I'm just consuming this stuff. And that nicety is something I'm willing to give up. But from an implementer's point of view, it's not just a syntax inconvenience.
那个人说，老实说，我承认C++的解决方案在这里更胜一筹。但这是我愿意做的。我不是实现者。我只是在消费这些东西。那种舒适感是我愿意放弃的。但从实现者的角度来看，这不仅仅是一个语法上的不便。
It's a tool that you no longer have to build your library. And I think he mentioned that like this was a huge gap that like a lot of people don't notice because a lot of like, the majority of folks are app, you know, writers, they're not library implementers. And so unless if you're talking to a library implementer, you're not really going to hear about this kind of missing piece, right? It's funny you should say that because I would, I mean, it's true, but everyone writes functions, everyone writes libraries because we write functions, we write APIs, right?
这是一个你不再拥有来构建你的库的工具。而且我认为他提到，这是一个巨大的差距，很多人没有注意到，因为大多数人是应用程序编写者，他们不是库实现者。所以除非你是在和库实现者交谈，否则你真的不会听到这种缺失的部分，对吧？你说得很有趣，因为我会……我的意思是，这是真的，但每个人都写函数，每个人都写库，因为我们写函数，我们写API，对吧？
Regardless of what we're doing. Very few, there are very few people who don't write functions. So regardless of whether you're an app writer or a library writer, I think variadic generics are super, super powerful. Yeah. And that's my, you know, I have a bias here. And my bias is that I haven't written a non-template in about six years professionally and I haven't
无论我们在做什么。很少，很少有人不写函数。所以无论你是应用程序编写者还是库编写者，我认为可变参数泛型都是超级超级强大的。是的。这就是我的，你知道，我在这里有偏见。我的偏见是，我在过去六年里没有在专业上写过非模板，而且我没有
written a non-variic template hardly in most of those six years so there you have it. What's your opinion? We've voiced ours now. We'll flip it back and now we're the interviewers again. On varietic templates? No, just everything. Is C++ on its way to dying?
在过去六年的大部分时间里写过非可变参数模板，所以这就是结果。你的意见是什么？我们现在已经表达了我们的观点。我们将把它翻转过来，现在我们又是采访者了。关于可变参数模板？不，只是关于一切。C++是否正在走向消亡？
Is it only in a second kind of winter as was the 2000s and we're about to get C++ 26 or 29 and it's gonna be a second boon, you know a golden age of C++ Well hmm, well I agree with you that There is just too much C++ code out there for it to ever truly die like it it won't whether C++ code out there for it to ever truly die like it it won't. Whether... The thing that might happen is it just loses mindshare. Like people just...
它是否只是处于像2000年代那样的第二个冬天，我们即将迎来C++ 26或29，它将迎来第二次繁荣，你知道C++的黄金时代？好吧，嗯，好吧，我同意你的观点，有太多的C++代码存在，它永远不会真正消亡，无论……有太多的C++代码存在，它永远不会真正消亡，它不会。无论……可能发生的事情是它只是失去了思想份额。就像人们只是……
The young people when they're learning to code they just think of C++ as an old language and they don't want to you know start using it and it becomes harder to hire C++ programmers because the ones that are there are starting to retire and people just move away from it for that reason. It just loses mindshare and in the end just sort of fizzles out for that reason. I think that's one of the dangers of, dangers if that's the right word, one of the potential futures just because I think you see it a lot already is that if I can generalize of younger coders like people who are just getting into it it seemed to gravitate more to more to rust than C++. It's seen as you know trendier if you like. So even outside of the safety thing that's that's something that could
年轻人学习编程时，他们只是认为C++是一门古老的语言，他们不想，你知道，开始使用它，而且因为现有的程序员开始退休，人们因为这个原因而远离它，所以雇佣C++程序员变得更加困难。它只是失去了思想份额，最终因为这个原因而逐渐消失。我认为这是危险之一，如果这是正确的词，潜在的未来之一，仅仅是因为我认为你已经看到了很多，如果我可以概括年轻的程序员，比如刚入门的人，他们似乎更倾向于Rust而不是C++。如果可以的话，它被视为更时髦。所以即使在安全问题之外，这也是可能
happen. In terms of safety yeah Ben you're right that the regulatory pressure might reduce. Companies of course, they always care about the bottom line. And if safer languages mean they're going to face fewer vulnerabilities, things that could cost them money, you know, that might be a reason that they choose to do it anyway, even outside of regulatory pressure. So, yeah, I would like to see a safe version of C++. I support kind of the goals that Sean Baxter had with Circle of coming up with...
发生的事情。在安全性方面，是的，Ben你是对的，监管压力可能会减少。公司当然总是关心底线。如果更安全的语言意味着他们将面临更少的漏洞，那些可能让他们花钱的事情，你知道，这可能是他们选择这样做的原因，即使在监管压力之外。所以，是的，我想看到一个安全的C++版本。我支持Sean Baxter用Circle提出的那种目标，提出……
It is really the subset of a superset thing that Herb and Bjarne have been talking about for a few years now. We want to expand the language with safe facilities and then have a safe subset that you can do most of your everyday programming in. I think that would be a good future for the language, but whether we can get there, I don't know. It's incredibly difficult. Yeah. And I mean, the committee, even if we do get there, it's going to take, I mean, stuff that supposedly a lot of the committee agrees on, it still takes up taking like a decade to
这确实是Herb和Bjarne几年来一直在谈论的超集的子集。我们想用安全设施扩展语言，然后有一个安全子集，你可以在其中进行大部分日常编程。我认为这对语言来说将是一个美好的未来，但我们是否能达到那里，我不知道。这极其困难。是的。而且我的意思是，委员会，即使我们确实达到了那里，它将需要……我的意思是，委员会中很多人据称同意的事情，仍然需要花费大约十年时间来
get in. Yeah. Yeah. And then it's like, it's the whole, the backwards compatibility is always the difficulty with C++. Even like you were saying with the tooling being problematic, but with any new language, or nowadays anyway, because people have learned the lesson, whenever a company comes with a new language, they will have, it will come with a build system, it will come with a linter,
进入。是的。是的。然后就像，这是整个……向后兼容性总是C++的困难所在。即使像你说的工具是有问题的，但对于任何新语言，或者现在无论如何，因为人们已经吸取了教训，每当一家公司带着一种新语言出现时，它都会有，它会带有一个构建系统，它会带有一个linter，
it will come with a source code formatter. And so people just have this from the start. And we could probably have a similar experience to what you get with cargo and Rust-up and that stuff. But it would mean that you would have to lay out your files in a particular way, and you'd have to give them a certain file extension or whatever. And the C++ people are hell no.
它会带有一个源代码格式化程序。所以人们从一开始就拥有这个。我们可能拥有与你在Cargo和Rust-up以及那些东西中获得的类似体验。但这将意味着你必须以特定的方式布局你的文件，你必须给它们一个特定的文件扩展名或其他什么。而C++的人是绝对不行的。
I want things to be standardized, but I want you to standardize it my way. So it's kind of a bit of a problem. Everyone wants nice at ease, but as long as they don't have to change what they're doing. C++ supports such a wide range of hardware that it is very diverse in terms of needs. I saw just this weekend, just last week, the C++ committee was meeting. Making a byte eight bits for C++26 was just dropped. A byte is not necessarily 8 bits because presumably there are hardware platforms out there that preclude us making that determination. So C++ is extremely supportive of diverse hardware.
我想要标准化，但我想要你用我的方式标准化它。所以这有点问题。每个人都想要好的东西，只要他们不必改变他们正在做的事情。C++支持如此广泛的硬件，以至于在需求方面非常多样化。我刚刚在这个周末，就在上周，C++委员会正在开会。为C++26将字节设为8位刚刚被放弃。字节不一定是8位，因为大概有硬件平台存在，阻止我们做出那个决定。所以C++对多样化硬件的支持非常强。
Yes, I had no idea that these platforms still existed, but apparently they do. From what I... So I don't know anything about this really, but from Google searches, I see that there is DSP hardware that is specialized to work with even 12 bits, 14 bits, 16 bits, where the tool chains just treat that size as their byte, I guess. And yes, why not? If you have a specialized piece of hardware that does one job and it just effectively has one data type to work on, then why would you spend the silicon to make bytes addressable, to make 8 bits addressable if you only ever work in 16 bits
是的，我不知道这些平台仍然存在，但显然它们存在。从我……所以我真的对此一无所知，但通过谷歌搜索，我看到有DSP硬件专门用于处理甚至12位、14位、16位，工具链只是把那个大小当作它们的字节，我想。是的，为什么不呢？如果你有一个专门的硬件做一项工作，它实际上只有一个数据类型可以处理，那么如果你只在16位中工作，为什么要花费硅片来使字节可寻址，使8位可寻址
I guess like I say, I really know nothing about it. So that's just Well, I'm surmising. All right. Do we want to put a bow on this is C++ dying second edition conversation any any final thoughts on Don't call the episode that I feel bad. I feel bad now slice of this conversation. Any final thoughts on? Don't call the episode that. I feel bad. I feel bad now. I was just curious about what you two thought. I don't want to... You gotta put these catchy titles though. C++ is still fun, right? We shouldn't lose sight of the fact that learning languages is fun. Learning C++ has a lot to offer. And I'm a big fan of languages in general.
我想就像我说的那样，我真的对此一无所知。所以这只是……好吧，我在推测。好了。我们想给这个“C++正在消亡第二版”的对话画上句号吗？关于……别把这期节目叫那个名字，我感到难过。我现在感到难过。对话的片段。关于……别把这期节目叫那个名字。我感到难过。我现在感到难过。我只是好奇你们两个怎么想。我不想……你得起这些吸引人的标题。C++仍然很有趣，对吧？我们不应该忽视学习语言很有趣的事实。学习C++有很多东西可以提供。而且我通常是语言的忠实粉丝。
Different languages have different things to offer and the reason to learn C++ in 2025 is the same as it's always been because it's because you learn things about how languages work, you learn things about how computers work because it's fun. Yeah. APL is fun too. I would argue more fun, but that's okay. I didn't say it wasn't. I didn't say it wasn't. That's just a slight APL.
不同的语言有不同的东西可以提供，在2025年学习C++的原因和以前一样，因为它是……因为你学习了关于语言如何工作的知识，你学习了关于计算机如何工作的知识，因为它很有趣。是的。APL也很有趣。我会说更有趣，但没关系。我没说它不是。我没说它不是。那只是对APL的一点点。
I can spell iota in a single glyph instead of, what is it? Three plus two colons for the namespace plus is nine, plus you need the parentheses and everything else that comes with it. But, you know, there's another reason I love C++. It borrows heavily from APL. All the numeric algorithms come straight from there, inner product, adjacent difference. And APL even gets, not only does APL get mentioned
我可以用一个字形拼写iota，而不是，它是什么？三个加两个冒号用于命名空间，加起来是九，加上你需要括号和随之而来的其他一切。但是，你知道，我喜欢C++的另一个原因。它大量借鉴了APL。所有的数值算法都直接来自那里，内积，相邻差。而且APL甚至得到，不仅APL得到提及
in from mathematics to generic programming, there is a line of APL code in from mathematics to generic programming. There's a whole page where Stepanov references both Kenneth Iverson's 79 Turing Award paper notation as a tool of thought and John Backus's Turing Award paper from the year before in 78. Can von Neumann languages be liberated from the von Neumann style? Yes, where he introduces the FP language, two of my favorite papers.
在《从数学到泛型编程》中，有一行APL代码在《从数学到泛型编程》中。有一整页，Stepanov引用了Kenneth Iverson的79年图灵奖论文《作为思维工具的符号》和John Backus前一年78年的图灵奖论文。冯·诺依曼语言能从冯·诺依曼风格中解放出来吗？是的，他在那里介绍了FP语言，这是我最喜欢的两篇论文。
And they're top five. I'm not sure if they're top five, but fantastic. They get referenced in like the same two paragraphs. And then I think he shows an example of a plus reduction. And so there's, there's APL, you know, if you weren't convinced by the passion that Stepanov has for the stories of mathematicians, you know, go read it for that one line of APL code. All right, we will, we will wrap up. I think that's episode two 23. And now we're starting episode two 24. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well
它们是前五名。我不确定它们是否是前五名，但非常棒。它们在相同的两段中被引用。然后我想他展示了一个加法归约的例子。所以有，有APL，你知道，如果你没有被Stepanov对数学家故事的热情所说服，你知道，去读读那一行APL代码。好了，我们将，我们将结束。我想那是第223期。现在我们开始第224期。请务必查看你的播客应用程序或adspthepodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及
as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个指向GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。